-Guys, today's Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and of course I send out
thank-you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I was running a bit behind.
So I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind just --
thank you -- I'd like to write
us some --
James, give us some thank-you
note writing music, please.
♪♪
-He has, like,
a goatee just to mock you.
-Yeah, that's kind
of weird to me.
-He didn't even grow
a whole beard.
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-He doesn't have a beard,
really.
It's more of a, uh --
-It's like a goatee
or a Van Dyke.
-It's like a --
[ Laughter ]
It's like a Mitch Miller-type
of vibe.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughs ]
Or a Van Dyke mustache.
-I mean, I can shave this thing.
I did it, I -- Tariq dared me,
I proved it,
I, you know, La Schmoove.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-I don't got nothing to prove.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't edit that.
-Don't edit.
-Man, La Schmoove, man.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you, Santa Con,
for looking like
a "Where's Waldo?"
for sober people.
It's like, "Oh, that person.
That person."
[ Applause ]
Thank you, car reindeer set,
for letting everyone on the road
know that you're a lot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let 'em go.
-Just let 'em go.
Let 'em pass you,
let 'em the other way,
we don't care, just -- yeah,
they've got something going on.
-They got some issues.
[ Imitating car horn,
scatting "La Cucaracha" ]
-Thank you, Harry and Meghan's
new Netflix documentary,
for getting King Charles to sign
up for Peacock.
Ooh, well, there you go.
That's one way to do it.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Thank you, Spotify Wrapped,
for reminding me
of that one night in May I fell
asleep with whale sounds
on repeat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Whale sounds? That's my song?
-What?
-You listened to it
for 1,500 minutes.
-1,500 minutes of whale sounds.
Fart noises are number two.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, opening one window
while driving,
for making me feel like
I'm getting an MRI
in the middle of a tornado.
It's like...
-[ Warbling sounds ]
[ Laughs ]
-Wub-wub-wub-wub-wub-wub-wub-
wub-wub-wub...
[ Singing "Chariots of Fire" ]
-Make it better, faster,
stronger.
-How's everything else going?
[ Laughter ]
How's that beard coming?
-It's throwing
the whole game off.
-Yeah, beard's messing
with your brain.
-It's just making me look, yeah.
-I mean, you never had it,
you know, really properly
sort of, you know.
-Wow.
-[Crowd] Oh!
-Wow. Properly sort of?
-I mean, you know...
-Properly sorted -- that --
-You never had it, like,
you know.
Like --
-Like what you have?
-I mean, you could never
have what I have.
-I don't --
-But, I mean --
-I don't live in the woods
for eight years.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
You never had it, like,
you know, connecting and --
-It looks like you're wearing
a disguise.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a Brawny paper towel.
-Yeah, I mean, you can see
who it is.
-What did Steve say yesterday?
Your beard looks like
a COVID mask
with a hole cut out in it.
[ Laughter ]
-He's right!
He's got a point.
[ Laughter ]
It's too thick.
-Yeah, no.
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you,
office Christmas parties
for having the rule --
liquor before beer,
you're in the clear.
Beer before liquor,
you'll see HR quicker.
There you go, okay.
There you go.
-I said that?
I said that?
-Thank you, Aaron Judge,
or as your family now calls you,
Santa.
There you have it, everybody.
Those were our thank-you notes.